i definitely have to ask you about
uh matrix because i'm a huge fan uh i've
heard through the grapevine that the
script is
fantastic uh i want to know what your
reaction was reading it for the first
time and meeting with lana for the first
time
sure my reaction to the script wow
people are really gonna like this
you know i said you know wow you know i
like this people really gonna like this
it's it's different and it's the same
you know at the same time so it's a
really really
very intelligent blend of what we want
and what we don't know what we may have
what we may not
know that we want um my my first meeting
with lana uh
was um wasn't even really an audition it
was it was just that it was a meeting it
was a you know
really uh about getting to know me and
getting to know
her and uh our our histories and how i
am as an actor you know lana is
um lana was was interested in creating a
family you know before she was
interested interested in creating a cast
and so
uh i was very fortunate enough to to be
welcomed welcoming
into that family you know uh and to be
over here in berlin
with that team making something really
special is this is a
it's definitely uh something that i'm
proud to you know probably say i'm a
part of
cannot effing wait um yeah yeah yeah man
congrats on everything um have a great
shoot
stay safe all right appreciate you take
care